uh there is major news coming out of the
house of representatives nancy pelosi
now says that the house of
representatives is indeed going to move
forward on an assault weapons ban there
was previously an assault weapons ban
that ran from 1994 to 2004 in the united
states and we will talk about that in a
moment speaker of the house nancy pelosi
says house democrats will soon consider
legislation banning military-style quote
assault weapons marking the most
aggressive response from congress to
date following last week's shooting
massacre at a texas elementary school
house democratic leaders have already
scheduled to vote next week on so-called
red flag legislation designed to keep
weapons from potentially violent people
the house judiciary committee is meeting
in an emergency session to mark up a
slate of eight additional anti-gun
violence bills including proposals to
ban high-capacity magazines and raise
the age for purchasing certain
semi-automatic rifles i am in favor of
all of this and also recognize that it
is not enough
and we're going to get back to that now
on the question of whether mass
shootings
went down during the assault weapons ban
and then went back up after it has been
examined by politifact and it has been
found to be mostly true joe biden said
when we passed the assault weapons ban
mass shootings went down
when the law expired mass shootings
tripled politifact has ruled that is
mostly true
their explanation is let me find it here
there are numbers that back biden up a
2019 study out of nyu school of medicine
found mass shooting deaths involving
assault weapons fell slightly in the
decade of the federal assault weapon ban
and then rose dramatically in the decade
that followed while other researchers
said the decline was too small to draw
firm conclusions there's no debate that
the pace and deadliness of shootings
went up after the ban ended beyond
assault weapons more recent work points
to the threat posed by large capacity
magazines which the 1994 law also
restricted that is also a factor with
the same guns but without the large
capacity magazines you would also see
less less death so
if you go back to last week i had my
segment where i laid out it was either
10 or 11 specific ideas on gun safety
and in that list i included
limiting certain firearms to 25 plus
some some are saying 21 plus i say 25
plus requiring mandatory gun insurance
requiring more extensive training and
re-licensing a mandatory waiting period
uh of of course reducing the ability to
have the high-capacity magazines a
mandatory initial and periodic mental
health evaluations
requiring two to three letters from
adults in the community
saying i have no concerns about this
individual under age 25 having firearms
i gave a long list but we actually need
to do more than that and of course
republicans are going to oppose this i
say that democrats in conjunction with
this bill to ban assault weapons again
which will it pass in the senate
probably not quite frankly unfortunately
they should um call the bluff of the
republicans saying well this is a mental
health issue
propose mental health legislation as
well
now of course part of that is red flag
laws
which would prevent individuals flagged
for concerning behavior um and and
diagnoses from it would prevent them
from getting weapons but
do something more significant require
require an initial mental health eval as
well as periodic ones now i know a lot
of people have raised the question
let's say you do that david what what
are you looking for is it just
a psychiatrist meets with everybody
and then evaluates for what what
conditions prevent you from getting a
gun how does anxiety compare with
borderline personality disorder compare
with if you've had a psychotic episode
well you've got to figure that out the
fact that it's complicated can't be a
reason not to do it i concede it's
complicated
but it absolutely needs to be done
if all of these things were in place
when it came to the shooter in texas
can't buy the weapons he bought because
he's under age 25 even to get a handgun
needs to have letters from the community
supposedly members in the community were
already some were already concerned
about this individual limits on high
capacity magazines waiting period
mandatory insurance which would have
made it more expensive and maybe
dissuaded although he reportedly spent a
bunch of money on the guns
those things at least had the chance the
chance of impacting that individual's
ability to get those firearms and those
bullets and to kill as many people could
he have ended up killing five
with a couple handguns yes
absolutely
but as tragic as those five deaths would
be
would we prefer five instead of 20 i
mean i would
i would so i would like to see democrats
not only push for the assault weapons
ban
propose some mental health legislation
to republicans including increased
funding as well
at the state level they don't want it
many states didn't even do the medicare
the medicaid expansion but that was part
of obamacare which would have increased
access as well so make them put up or
shut up make them go on record as
opposing the mental health legislation
they're the ones claiming that's the
first thing to look at we'll look at it
but also look at guns and we've got to
look at a lot of other things i am sure
i will get many questions on this topic
on our upcoming town hall
that will be tuesday june 14th at 6 pm
eastern streaming live on the pacman
live youtube channel that's the other
youtube channel make sure you're
subscribed there for free and i look
forward to speaking to lots of you then
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chili sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get 30 off of the uhler
and cube sleep systems and 10 off the
new doc pro this software is only for my
audience the link is down below